you guys saw the Dalai Lama thing where
like he tells the kid to suck his tongue
been jerking off to it all weekend
so can I say one thing about that real
quick yeah that like and you're never
gonna see me on a podcast actually
saying this but
China might be right about Tibet clip it
China might be right about Tibet I've
been hearing this Tibetan people for the
longest saying free Tibet free Tibet
from China's occupation or free Tibet
whatever it's like if that's what your
leader is doing with kids bruh
China might be right about Tibet bro
China might be right right should we at
least hear China out maybe if the leader
the number one dude is saying suck my
tongue to kids he is the god of
compassion spelled c-u-m-p-a-s-s-i-o-s
I'm just saying we got to hear China out
if I'm JiJi ping I'm putting this video
on Tick Tock and I'm gonna see
what I'm talking about
you want this free because you want the
weird [__] is that this happened in
February
like it's only popping up now and so I'm
like oh yeah China sauce [__] popping
up on Tick Tock they're propagating it
everywhere that's where I first saw go
viral was on Tick Tock I'd be okay if
they they invaded But with that being
said I'd be okay someone need to invade
Tibet someone need to get him out of
here I think this is this is he's just
trying to one up Biden
he's taken Biden's rule book and he's
trying to be a great world leader and
he's like what does Biden do he sniffs
little kids okay so now he's going full
tongue sucker
he's going yo suck my tongue I mean yeah
that's that's yeah we got to get Biden
out of here too bro like I'll be honest
if Biden kept up the sniffing because I
think he's had they have the snip in
that bay but like if he kept up the
sniffing
yeah where's he gonna sit this is what
happens to all religious leaders that
have to do away with all their urges
[Laughter]
I will say at least he's giving at least
he's offering something yes or just
taking [__] monsters but I will say
this it is it is odd and you know God
Rest the dead and obviously R.I.P the
great the great one Gandhi but there was
that little kid [__] going on with him
right everybody get bad push back when
you hit them with this dude
act like they act like it should take
away from his greatness that he used
kids for fuel to do those things yeah
yeah like he wasn't eating for so long
because he was sucking kids off right
like yeah he could go okay all right all
right let me just say I'm gonna say it I
don't care I got I got you yeah yeah
it you let him babysit yeah you're gonna
like come on me bro come on bro Gandhi's
been reincarnated in this Society he
understands Maybe
We Are All One
Gandhi got married at 13 his wife was
11. 13 year olds then were not what 13
year olds are now talk that [__] okay
[__] blackbird
talk that [__] I hate that I told you
about this [__] [__] that [__] Larry
Hall 13 now I'm not saying 1990s 30. I'm
saying 1890s 13. right 13 back in the
day was old right that's when women
started having kids I mean according to
Jews it was they were adults back then
back then you were 13 Bat Mitzvah adult
that's what it was because they didn't
have this extended childhood you were an
adult you got these married out the
house but that's not what he was doing
he was an adult During adult times and
then he was sleeping with kids in the
room you know how thirties the new 40.
13 is the old 18. but 13 is the old 18.
but what about when he was old and the
kids were sleeping in a room with him to
test his results did he do anything
only they know there you go he passed
the test he did nothing he passed bro
yeah this is from Michael Jackson
yeah but here's the thing
with 20 year olds because he's two years
old if I got like a chocolate addiction
right and I'm trying to get over it
maybe I would sleep with some chocolate
right because that chocolate would be
right there calling my name right and I
gotta know that I gotta break this
chocolate yeah
kids in the room he's admitting to
attraction that that's the tricky I know
I think people back then were attracted
to 13 year olds because you were getting
married at 11. so a 13 year old Den is
like a 20 year old now 21 years old so
you're saying they just carry that
attraction until they're older that
doesn't stop yeah they just looked at
them as women in the way that we don't
the society this is healthier and better
I'm sure and you haven't ex but also
back then you didn't have a childhood
where you're like playing with dolls at
like 13 you're a man get the [__] out of
the house
that is an interesting thing that you're
saying right there it's a crazy thing to
say but I gotta stand on it because it's
gone no man it I it sounds like I'm
about to make fun of you I'm not going
to make fun of you I actually think
that's a really interesting argument
which is like but do you think that that
13 is the best for him
that's they just looked at it as okay
you have as soon as you're ready to have
kids you're a woman well I wasn't eight
like why do you have like an 18 year old
fine [__] in there son 18 year old she
you might be dying 18 back then 18 year
old back then you like cicada I gotta
get it I get it no I'm seeing what
you're saying I get it I don't get it
but I get it yeah I see what you're
saying yeah yeah
exactly so yeah 13. she's like 30. yeah
yeah 13 going on 30. that's what that
movie's about that's exactly what it's
about I've seen it
it's him picking up chicks bro that's a
great argument for what God did he
didn't know no better son that was
suicidal
13 was an old [__]
yeah when she started having kids I
think 13 she had their first kid if I'm
not mistaken it was 13 and 15 and maybe
17. I could just be making that up but
for sure she had a kid by Third so he
was smashing an 11 year old that's a
fact as a 13 year old that's that's an
important part he was 13. you keep
saying he was an adult adult then later
on when he was an adult what they say is
he would sleep with 13 year old girls in
bed with him naked and not do anything
to test his
absence
don't believe Michael you don't believe
Mike no you crack ass
Michael don't need to touch no [__]
touch them no those kids got to sleep
with Mike yeah the other way around yeah
he can't compare Gandhi to Michael
Jackson yeah God he didn't make any
music Michael Jackson
he's more talented but he's not better
Michael Jackson
globally for sure globally yeah yeah he
didn't impact much societally except
those dudes buttholes they weren't full
dudes that's that's true
people cry for Michael Jackson then for
Gandhi I don't know anybody who cries
for Gandhi no disrespect obviously
that's false he died in 1946 did people
cry yeah billions of people what
he had his first kids at 16-7 he was 16
to 17. she was 17. no Gandhi 16 and his
wife age 17. no they didn't wait six six
years to have kids they did not but is
his wife older than him no she was 13
she was 11 he was 13. I'm fairly certain
God damn imagine you got that wrong bro
disconnect Dove's internet right now
that's racist but you think he controls
the internet that's [__] up you really
think that Michael Jackson was touching
them kids you think that's why you
always had the Band-Aids on his fingers
you think he was
you think he was blistered up for a
minute or what nah he was just biting
until they bite back yeah
the spotted dick it was a spot that was
bruises yeah come on wow dude now it all
makes sense but I still don't believe he
didn't I never heard the spot addicting
you didn't hear the spot today he's
young bro he don't know nothing about it
I saw it I saw it I don't remember it
though it wouldn't be invited yeah he
would you wouldn't have made the cut
yeah I didn't like Michael like that
back in the day